and you can see that hector's already
getting to work doing something else
because today is alex
international waffle day yes one local
business is donating stacks of waffles
to raise funds for the ccsd police k-9
team
and hector mejia has been there cooking
up waffles all morning long hey hector
good morning hey there good morning guys
you know i sure hope these officers do
not feel
waffle after eating dozens possibly
hundreds or even
thousands of waffles so this is the one
i made earlier and uh
we're going to go ahead and give this
we're going to cover
these we're going to cover the
marshmallows
and this especially made for sergeant
ryan sink who's right here there you go
sergeant
you wanted whipped cream on your waffle
i did yes
so hey yeah we're going to be out here
today we're going to eat waffles we're
going to be drinking coffee and they're
also going to be selling look at this
artwork this is done by one of their
employees here
at the waffle shop uh these bags the
coffee is roasted right here in las
vegas right down the street and they're
gonna be selling these and the proceeds
are also gonna go to the k9 team so if
you don't
can't come out and eat waffles please
come by back buy a bag of coffee it
smells fantastic
so we're gonna have a whole group of
ccsd police officers here
in just a few hours starts at nine
o'clock in case you want to put this on
your calendar
um we're raising money for the k9 team
you were telling me that two more
canines
are joining the force which is great
news wonderful yes we're excited we're
getting another springer and then
another dog to be determined so
those officers are going through
training right now so we're super
excited and again
all the funds raised here are going to
go directly to the team to support the
equipment that they need the training
they need to keep the kids in
clark county safe and in case you didn't
know those dogs are not like these scary
looking
well for some they might be scary
looking the german shepherds i've been
bitten by a dog before
but they're like the sweet cute looking
dogs yeah they are we've got labs and we
got springers they
are not formidable at all we call them
floppier dogs
so as soon as they come in and do their
job they usually hang out at all the
schools let the kids pet them and
believe me they do love their belly rubs
so they will flop right over and put
that put that belly right up and you
know
as long as you talk to the handler make
sure it's good to go those dogs will
love it
sergeant thank you we're going to let
your belly enjoy that waffle right there
looks delicious
and we are at this coffee and waffle
we're going to talk with tiffany real
quick before we run out of time because
you know if you guys are watching
everyone watching at home you want to
come on down here and celebrate
international waffle day
you get to buy one and you get the other
one half off
nice yes um lastly i just ran out of
breath
yeah you can build your own waffles and
just join the team in celebrating
i'm going to put a little nutella on
yours hector
yeah there we go and alex and john
believe it or not this is that ugly
looking waffle i made
in the last hour and look how delicious
it looks with the powder with the sugar
it's a churro waffle with the drizzled
chocolate and the uh strawberries
i'm actually gonna eat this one i really
am cause i'm hungry
hector we are crying in here watching
you oh my gosh you almost dropped
well i hope the sergeant enjoys his
waffle with his whipped cream
uh you're doing a minute you
[Laughter]
he's like sorry i can't all right i need
a break
okay okay well you go take a break get
some water we need one too goodness
thank you sporty